el lupus es una enfermedad en la cual el
sistema inmunológico ataca a los tejidos
de su propio cuerpo
el sistema inmunológico está compuesto
de glóbulos blancos que defienden al
cuerpo ante invasores extraños
normalmente cuando invasores extraños
como virus y bacterias ingresan al
cuerpo
algunos de los glóbulos blancos los
identifican como extraños porque
contienen sustancias llamadas antígenos
este reconocimiento provoca que algunos
de los glóbulos blancos produzcan
marcadores químicos llamados anticuerpos
estos anticuerpos se adhieren a los
antígenos marcando a los invasores
extraños como objetivos en el sistema
inmunológico para destruirlos
en una enfermedad autoinmune como el
lupus los glóbulos blancos hacen
anticuerpos erróneamente para marcar
algunas de las células de su propio
cuerpo y circular productos químicos
para la destrucción cuando los
anticuerpos se adhieren a sus células
normales
los glóbulos blancos comienzan a
atacarlos como si fueran antígenos
extraños
con el tiempo esta respuesta inmune
provoca inflamación en las partes del
cuerpo donde sea que ocurra este ataque
la inflamación hace que los vasos
sanguíneos en el área afectada se
expandan y derramen fluido provocando
enrojecimiento e hinchazón
los síntomas del lupus ocurren a medida
que el sistema inmunológico comienza a
atacar diferentes áreas del cuerpo
usted puede desarrollar un exantema en
alas de mariposa en la piel de las
mejillas y la nariz pueden formarse
pequeñas llagas o úlceras dentro de la
nariz y la boca
usted podría desarrollar artritis en la
cual las articulaciones se inflaman y se
hinchan
cuando los dedos están fríos pueden
volverse de color azul o blanco a esto
se le conoce como fenómeno de reina
podría sentir dolor durante una
respiración profunda provocada por la
pleuresía una afección en la cual el
recubrimiento externo de los pulmones
está inflamado los glóbulos blancos
pueden crear anticuerpos que se adhieren
a partes de su adn de células gastadas
el par ha adherido llamado complejo
inmune puede albergar se en los riñones
y provocar inflamación
esta afección se conoce como nefritis
lúpica
la recaída de cualquiera de sus síntomas
incluso aquellos no relacionados con la
piel puede deberse a una reacción
inusual a la luz solar llamada foto
sensibilidad
otros síntomas comunes del lupus
incluyen cansancio extremo
dolores de cabeza fiebre
disminución de los glóbulos rojos en la
sangre conocida como anemia
hinchazón de las piernas pies manos o la
piel alrededor de los ojos
dolor muscular y debilidad
y pérdida de cabello
al lupus a veces lo llaman el gran
imitador porque sus diversos síntomas se
encuentran en otros problemas de salud
no hay cura para el lupus sin embargo
usted puede prevenir o reducir las
recaídas al evitar la luz directa del
sol y utilizar bloqueador solar en el
exterior
el bloqueador solar debe tener un factor
de protección solar de 55 o mayor y
proteger contra la radiación
ultravioleta y la radiación
ultravioleta-b
para tratar sus síntomas su médico puede
recomendarle una combinación de
medicamentos para reducir la inflamación
como los medicamentos antiinflamatorios
no esteroideos aine y medicamentos
contra la malaria
su médico también podría recomendarle
medicamentos que suprimen o previenen
que el sistema inmunológico ataque a los
tejidos de su cuerpo como los
corticoesteroides